there's a story coming out of texas a
school shooting
usually the media blasts school
shootings all over
the tv and the newspapers and everywhere
this one though you may not have heard
about so much
the reason that you may not have heard
about it is that it contradicts the
prevailing narrative on school shootings
how does it do that because in the
prevailing narrative on school shootings
all the shooters are white
uh in this case the school shooter was
black
furthermore it contradicts a lot of the
narrative on on criminal justice because
what we always hear is that the cops go
really easy on white people and they're
really harsh on black people
but in this case the 18 year old student
who shot up at texas high school
was just released on bail
he shoots
four people
injures four people
shoots up the school and he gets
released
on bail
and so i don't i don't i was very sad
it's sad whenever anyone
shoots up a school or shoots up a
community or you know commits any active
violence
but
that doesn't necessarily make it a
national news story i mean these things
do happen the reason i mention this
story
is to point out
that this sort of thing never would have
happened if the kid were white if this
if the school shooter were a white kid
he never would have been released on
bail there would be marches there would
be
wall-to-wall news coverage
and
and there isn't now because it
contradicts that narrative and i don't
want to fall into the trap of saying you
know if they're sure on the other foot
or you know if the roles were reversed
it doesn't matter if the rules were
reversed there were double standards in
this country but you got to point it out
when it happens you have to be aware of
it because some people i think are still
locked in that matrix more on that in
just one second first though did you
know that over 80 percent of the
grass-fed beef sold in the united states
is imported from overseas
well
it might be local in guatemala or
something but it's not local here which
is why the good ranchers have gone out
to american ranches to bring american
meat to the american consumer all at an
incredible
price head on over to
goodranchers.com you get better than
organic chicken you'll get american
craft beef they have t-bones fillets
strips gourmet burgers and more
at half the price of online competitors
you will get the steakhouse quality you
deserve the price every family can
afford
i really love good ranchers they got all
the cuts you want t-bones fillets strips
for me this is going to sound kind of
basic i love those burgers their gourmet
burgers are magnificent go to
goodranchers.com knowles right now save
20 bucks or better yet subscribe and
save on each box of mouth-watering
american meats that will show up on
schedule right to your door that is 20
off and free express shipping if you go
to goodranchers.com
knowlescanwlis or use code knowles at
checkout 20 bucks off and free shipping
at goodranchers.com
knowles
one of the most persistent
myths canards
uh from
the the left's narrative on race and the
criminal justice system and specifically
on school shootings and church shootings
and race relations
is that
dylan roof he's the guy who shot up a
black church in south carolina
dylan roof when he was arrested he was
he was taken alive he wasn't killed in
in
the act and he was taken alive and the
cops took him to burger king have you
heard this lie
the cops first of all the cops didn't
take
an arrested
mass shooter to burger king okay nobody
could you imagine the cashier at burger
king if the cops walk in with this
deranged killer no obviously that didn't
happen the cops arrested him but they
did bring him burger king
okay why did they bring him burger king
because they had to feed him it is the
law that no matter how heinous a crime a
person commits you have to protect
certain basic rights including their
right not to be starved they have to be
fed
furthermore the reason the cops bought
dylann roof burger king is because if
they didn't if they didn't get them food
if they didn't
satisfy these basic requirements of the
law
he might have been able to get off the
hook
or at least it would have raised
problems for the trial because he and
his lawyers could have claimed that his
rights were violated and it would have
complicated the trial and would have
made it harder to punish him buying
burger king for that shooter for dylan
roof
made it easier to punish him it was a
tool and an instrument in order to
bring justice to that shooter okay
in this case you're not going to hear
anything about that
he was led off the hook he was released
on bail you're not going to hear
anything about that because it doesn't
fit the the racial narrative
remember this story remember this story
the next time the left brings it up
the next time the left tries to
construct one of these kooky
kooky racial narratives about it okay
it's just
not
true i'm so glad you like that clip i
liked it too but i'm glad that we can
agree on that
subscribe to this channel please i'm
begging you i'm begging you it's the
only way to help us get past some of the
censorship here on youtube and if you
want the full uncensored youtube doesn't
have any say over it uh version of this
show you got to get the audio podcast
it's free the michael knowles show
at apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play head on over wherever you
get your podcasts that is t-h-e space
m-i-c-h-a-e-l space k-n-w-l-e-s space
s-h-o-w period t-h-a-n-k-s
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]